c'est l'histoire d'un paradoxe qui
gangrène la seine saint denis depuis des
années pourquoi ce département situé aux
portes de paris
stagner dans la pauvreté alors qu'il
bénéficie de nombreux atouts
c'est la question que s'est posée
l'institut montaigne leur enquête détail
plusieurs points et propose même des
solutions en seine saint denis les
initiatives ne manquent pas le
département regroupe 500 bissieux projet
avec le grand paris
le cdg express les infrastructures pour
les jo
le développement du terminal 4 de
l'aéroport charles de gaulle et enfin
elle la réalisation du campus hospitalo
universitaires grand paris nord en tout
près de 20 milliards d'euros
d'investissements publics répartis sur
les 15 prochaines années
sauf que ce dynamisme économique profite
peu aux habitants près d'un tiers vivent
avec moins de 1000 60 euros par mois et
les jeunes sont particulièrement touchés
par le chômage puisque 28% des personnes
âgées de 18 à 24 ans sont sans emploi ni
formation soit 13 points de plus que
dans les hauts-de-seine par exemple
selon l'institut montaigne chaque jour
près de 300000 personnes viennent
travailler dans le département soit 43 %
des emplois du territoire l'explication
est bien l'offre d'emploi de cadres et
professions intellectuelles supérieures
est plus élevé que les besoins de la
main d'oeuvre locale
ainsi les employeurs sont donc
contraints de recourir à des personnes
extérieures tandis que les résidents
sont donc poussé à sortir du département
pour travailler
l'enquêté révèle également l'absence
d'une véritable stratégie dans le
domaine de l'éducation
les enseignants débutants sont affectés
dans des établissements difficiles et
une importante partie de reste moins de
deux ans au même poste à titre d'exemple
49 % des professeurs à l'école ne sont
pas remplacés pour une moyenne de 22 % à
l'échelle nationale
des absences qui peuvent avoir de
lourdes conséquences sur l'éducation des
élèves
il ya aussi le cas des étudiants issus
des quartiers populaires qu'on laisse
tomber dès qu'ils arrivent à
l'université il ne bénéficie d'aucun
suivi ni de réseau
et finissent par s'inscrire au chômage
l' enquête suggère que les opérateurs
mandatée pour accompagner les élèves
jusqu'à l'emploi devrait bénéficier de
financements plus importants
autre élément significatif dans le
budget du département
les fonds qui devrait être dédiée à
l'insertion sont absorbés par le coût du
versement des prestations du rsa ce
montant s'élève à 505 millions d'euros
pour seulement 317 millions d'euros de
recettes
dès lors il est impossible de créer une
dynamique à la hauteur des enjeux
les projets sont là le potentiel aussi
mais le département a besoin d'être
repensé et aborder de manière différente
et avec la crise sanitaire liée aux
copies 19 la situation pourrait se
dégrader
l'enquète l'a démontré il faut donc plus
de moyens et une répartition des chances
égalitaire pour permettre au département
d'exploiter ses capacités